and now he is being a bigot Lee I mean
on one side is talking about profit
moments or some he doesn't understand
that prophet Mohamed Salah Nephilim when
he came how many was really participate
in how many people did he kill by his
sworn he doesn't even know that
historically the sword of Methuselah it
killed only one enemy can you imagine
that how many was really participated in
how many people were killed a lot of
wars that took place at the time of
Prophet Muhammad I have a background to
it yeah and those backgrounds I'm not
very sure this guy has never studied
talk talk rook before we go to break
someone might say what do you mean just
11 you said that only one person was
killed by his sword yes elaborate on
this I mean see if a battle is solved
and if he's the person was too
interested to be violent and kill
enemies he should have killed hundreds
of them thousands of them but then you
find that only one person is killed
through its own that means he is not a
warlord but everyone testifies about
profit bombers Islam Allah testifies in
the Quran in for ambience for a number
21 has the more info on mama arsenic is
a little Malala mean we did not send you
but as a mercy to the entire universe
and mercy is that the people were
innocent should be given mercy and
forgiveness and the people who are
criminals shall be dealt with justice so
now if some criminal is being dealt with
justice that is not being of our Lord if
American national security is defended
by attacking the enemies of America by
going for war with the enemies of
America you are not going to call that
Americans are more loads you're going to
say they're defending the national
security and if it is done in the just
cause then it for just one yeah so that
is how the history of Islam goes with
prophet muhammad saw club his words were
just wars and look at the teachings you
study Polamalu g the subject in which
you study about what and you come to
understand that there are different
categories of wars and all the work that
the purpose alone isn't what were just
was just worse yes it wasn't like he was
going to picking on people absolutely
not absolutely not i mean this is what
the came and strong you even yeah that
historian they testify gandhi that's
interesting about guy with no bread but
he after he was finished reading the
ography a problem hamat he was sad he
was what he was why would he that I mean
for an intellectual thinking about he
was known for his nonviolent protest
that's why would he be sad and why would
he be talking about yeah I appraising a
violent war lord mayor lawful but
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
we're making sense of it all through
truth because you're talking you're
getting to know the Muslims make the
human connection we'll be right back
with more God willing double anywhere
[Applause]